she was the biggest star of the 2004
games but when the competition ends
where do you go you gotta be [ __ ]
kidding me
for bronze medalist hope and Gregory you
go home all of America talking about
your [ __ ] bronze I am a gold medalist
you don't want to [ __ ] with whoever I
want whenever I want with them so hard
I'll whip their eggs in half and or one
part of the tape and I'll lock it
bring my neck and the other half the
tate lock at your mom just shove a Prius
thank you hey you hope twitchy
yeah no one really calls me that anymore
in fact you were the only person that
that did it so different oh really
but that's still there so now I see it
check the resume have you thought any
more about working at the gym
I'm not coach I'm a star I was I'm
Dancing with the Stars it's not called
Dancing with the coaches I'm gonna show
you how to be judge wait keep to the
right keep to the left not on cute not a
cute sell it to the bitch-ass judges
yeah de toast a standard oh Christ no
one's on Planet bonanza
deonda Swanzey de dar de NOS dicen
conciencia kasi